[Applaus]
[Musik]
sicher habt ihr irgendwann schon mal mit
euren freunden darüber diskutiert aus
welchem grund die mietpreise überall auf
der welt so steil in die höhe schießen
egal ob in münchen los angeles oder
landen
wir sprechen hier von einem wirklich
globalen phänomen das in allen großen
metropolen anzutreffen ist
vor allem aber sollten wir uns erst mal
die frage stellen ob dieser anstieg
tatsächlich problematisch ist oder ob
sich diese entwicklung noch in einem
wirtschaftlich sinnvollen rahmen
abspielt
[Musik]
worum auch immer es sich handelt schauen
wir uns zunächst die auswirkungen an in
der stadt los angeles zum beispiel ist
die durchschnittsmiete in den letzten
drei jahren um 15 prozent gestiegen
thema mit einem ordentlichen gehalt
stellt dass er eine unannehmlichkeit als
ein existenzielles problem da aber stell
dir vor du würdest in ihr leben und als
verkäuferin oder verkäufer in einem
ladengeschäft arbeiten welche
auswirkungen hätte diese entwicklung auf
deine finanzielle situation als
verkäuferin im einzelhandel würdest du
wahrscheinlich etwas 2.000 us dollar im
monat verdienen eine 50 quadratmeter
große einzimmerwohnung im süden von los
angeles der preis nicht am günstigsten
ist kann die miete gut 1.200 us dollar
pro monat kosten
[Musik]
das wären 60 prozent seines gehalts der
rest würde für alle anderen
grundlegenden lebenshaltungskosten die
essen und kleidung draufgehen in einer
solchen situation fällt es extrem schwer
geld zu sparen
der idealfall sieht anders aus
miete oder hypothekenzahlungen sollten
nicht mehr als ein drittel seines
gehalts ausmachen damit genug für einen
einigermaßen komfortablen lebensstil
übrig bleibt und du auch noch etwas geld
für außergewöhnliche anschaffungen
altersvorsorge oder die in den usa
äußerst hohen studiengebühren eine
kinder an sparen kannst wenn aber 60
prozent des einkommens für miete drauf
gehen kann einen schon ein kleiner
anstieg der preise aus der bahn werfen
da landet man dann auch ganz schnell mal
unterhalb der armutsgrenze und ja dieses
risiko ist realer als viele glauben
wollen
die zahl der obdachlosen in los angeles
steigt dramatisch an auf 36.000 aber das
ist noch lange nicht das ende der
fahnenstange denkt mal darüber nach wie
wir euch hier bei visual politik immer
davon erzählt wie die welt besser wird
die menschen werden im schnitt immer
wohlhabender gesünder und der weltweite
lebensstandard steigt beständig das
liegt zum teil daran dass die dinge
billiger werden die ein beispiel in den
siebziger jahren konnten sich nur 20
prozent der amerikaner leisten jemals in
ihrem leben mit einem flugzeug zu
verreisen wieso weil ein flug von los
angeles nach new york damals
inflationsbereinigt 1500 dollar gekostet
hat nun genau dieser flug kostet heute
nur noch 200 dollar ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass ihr dank dessen öfter mit
einem flugzeug geflogen seit als eure
großeltern in eurem alter
dasselbe gilt für viele andere waren und
dienstleistungen alles wird immer
erschwinglicher außer häuser
egal ob ihr mietet oder kauft ihr müsst
dafür in der regel mehr opfer bringen
als die generation ihrer großeltern
heute ist es in städten wie stockholm
nichts außergewöhnlich ist dass menschen
in 15 vertrag mit der großen wohnung
leben dort kommt es zum beispiel auch
öfter vor dass sich viele vollkommen
zerstrittene paare noch jahrelang
zusammenraufen müssen weil sie darauf
warten dass einer von ihnen eine neue
wohnung findet und erst mal hand aufs
herz kann man ein solches land
eigentlich noch einen wohlfahrtsstaat
nennen aber die eigentliche frage hier
lautet warum steigen die mietpreise
derart könnte man dieses problem mit
einer besseren politik lösen heute
werden wir diese fragen beantworten aber
vorher wollen wir einen blick zurück in
die geschichte werden
[Musik]
angebot nachfrage und der rest
so gut wie jedem land der welt wächst
die zahl der einwohner noch vor einem
jahrzehnt lebt in den usa 300 millionen
menschen jetzt sind es 27 millionen mehr
aber das wachstum vollzieht sich ganz
und gar nicht gleichmäßig wenn wir uns
die lage in detroit oder cleveland
anschauen stellen wir fest dass dort
immer weniger menschen leben
sie verlassen die stadt und wo gehen sie
hin ganz genau in wohlhabende städte wie
los angeles oder new york
und was bedeutet das das bedeutet dass
die nachfrage nach wohnungen in diesen
städten immer weiter steigt das ist
völlig in ordnung und natürlich und nun
kommen wir zum wahren ursprung des
problems in einem normalen markt kann
das angebot steigen um die nachfrage zu
befriedigen
schauen wir uns zum beispiel die
ölmärkte an wir haben euch hier bei
visual politik oft davon erzählt wie
saudi arabien seine ölproduktion je nach
bedarf des marktes verringert oder
erhöht bei öl ist das nämlich relativ
leicht man kann die produktion von einem
monat auf den anderen erhöhen oder
senken aber wenn es um immobilien geht
müssen mehr häuser gebaut werden damit
das angebot wächst und das braucht zeit
außerdem ist die investitionssumme für
eine großes mehrfamilienhaus recht hoch
und die gewinnmargen liegen bei etwa
drei prozent die jetzige situation ist
so dass wir sehr sehr viele neue häuser
brauchen um den bedarf zu decken
kalifornien müsste bis 2025 3,5
millionen wohneinheiten bauen um seine
wohnung lücke zu schließen
[Musik]
kalifornien müsste bis 2025 35 millionen
wohneinheiten bauen um seine wohnung
lücke zu schließen
auszug aus dem bericht des mckinsey
global institute oktober 2016
aber warum haben bauherren so große
probleme mit dem bau von häusern
wir sprechen darüber geschäftsleute bei
so viel nachfrage könnte man doch ein
tolles geschäft mit wohnungen in
kalifornien machen oder nun natürlich
kannst du das es gibt nur ein problem
bauvorschriften bebauungspläne und viele
andere vorkehrungen mit denen die
politik und die behörden den
immobilienmarkt streng regulieren wenn
man den bauen möchte braucht man eine
baugenehmigung und die zu bekommen kann
mehr als drei jahre dauern wo wie und
was gebaut werden darf liegt nun mal in
den händen der kommunalpolitiker und
beamten aber woher weiß man in den
rathäusern wie viele wohnungen überhaupt
möglich werden zunächst einmal werden
statistiken zum bevölkerungswachstum
herangezogen
[Applaus]
wenn man nun zb in los angeles das
wachstum der zahl an wohnungen mit denen
der bevölkerung vergleicht erkennt man
dass diese durchaus korrelieren
oberflächlich betrachtet ist dann doch
alles in ordnung oder ganz und gar nicht
denn die bevölkerungszahl ist eine sache
und die reale nachfrage eine ganz andere
stellt euch zum beispiel ein paar vor
dass in einem haus wohnt wenn sich die
beiden scheiden lassen brauchen sie
plötzlich eine zusätzliche wurde und
voller bei gleicher bevölkerungszahl
haben wir gerade doppelt so viel
nachfrage geschaffen
die realität sieht nämlich so aus dass
die zahl von singles und geschiedenen
immer weiter steigt und nicht nur in
allen so in madrid berlin und fast jeder
anderen stadt viele experten sind der
meinung dass die lösungen darin bestünde
einfach noch mehr häuser zu bauen andere
setzen sich für die abschaffung von
beschränkungen durch bebauungspläne ein
aber in europa setzen viele städte auf
mit preiskontrollen glaubt ihr dass eine
solche politik funktioniert ist es eine
gute oder eine schlechte idee
schauen wir uns das mal etwas aus der
nähe an
[Musik]
das andere stockholm-syndrom wenn wir
über schweden sprechen dann meist
deshalb weil wir es als positives modell
heranziehen die menschen in schweden
genießen einen großzügigen sozialstaat
und ebenso eine dynamische wirtschaft
mit innovativen unternehmen darunter
befindet sich zb europas berühmtester
start ob auch wenn es vielleicht nicht
mehr lange in schweden bleiben trotzdem
heiß drohen schweden zu verlassen
beflügeln starter protest in stockholm
warum wollen
da gab's schweden verlassen wegen der
hohen steuern nicht wirklich der
hauptgrund ist dass sie keine
talentierten mitarbeiter aus dem ausland
einstellen können und jetzt wenn es du
vielleicht einkommen schon mag jeder
weiß dass schweden berühmt ist für seine
kultur der offenheit gegenüber migranten
und ja das ist es in der tat nur leider
haben jede migranten welche diese
unternehmen brauchen sind
außerordentlich viel pech zb bei der
wohnungssuche in stockholm
[Musik]
wären wir für dieses video
recherchierten sprachen wir mit einem
mann der anderthalb jahre lang für ein
schwedisches start-up gearbeitet hat er
verdient ein gehalt von 2900 euro im
monat aber mehr als die hälfte davon
ging für die miete seiner 45
quadratmeter wohnung drauf und glaubt
mir das war nicht der schlimmste fall
eine wohnung in stockholm zu finden ist
so schwer dass manche leute monate auf
einem rbi zimmer bringen in der
täglichen hoffnung doch noch durch eine
glückliche fügung einen langfristigen
mietvertrag zu ergattern
warum aber hat die wohnungsnot wittstock
von derart krasse züge angenommen alles
begann in den 50er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts schweden brauchte häuser so
schuf die sozialdemokratische regierung
das sogenannte millionen programm die
idee war in kurzer zeit eine million
staatlicher sozialwohnungen zu bauen
einer bevölkerung von rund acht
millionen einwohner
damals hatte jeder schwede anspruch auf
eine staatliche wohnung zu geregelten
mieten die heute drei bis vierhundert
euro entsprechen
[Musik]
und da fiel auf diese tolle möglichkeit
zurückgriffen war sowohl das interesse
der mitte an privat vermieteten objekten
also von investoren diese privaten
wohnungen zu bauen sehr gering denn alle
wollten in die sozialwohnungen
hinzu kommt dass die ganze bauwirtschaft
der jetzt mit dem bau der
sozialwohnungen beschäftigt war
aber die dinge änderten sich in den 90er
jahren schlagartig in diesen jahren
durchlebte schweden eine der schlimmsten
finanzkrisen seiner geschichte die
staatsschulden schossen in die höhe und
muslime aus die maus mit den staatlich
garantierten haus was aber blieb war der
mietpreis deckel
wer jetzt keine staatliche soziale
wohnung mehr bekommen hatte sah sich nun
mit einem extrem verknappten privaten
mietmarkt konfrontiert heute ist es in
schweden noch immer tradition ist erst
mal auf dem staatlich regulierten
wohnungsmarkt zu versuchen dass sie da
etwas so aus
[Musik]
als schwede ist das erste was man tun
sobald man das achtzehnte lebensjahr
erreicht hat sich für eine staatliche
wohnung zu gewähren wenn man glück hat
bekommt man nach einer wartezeit von
etwa 13 jahren eine zweizimmerwohnung
sie nur 600 euro im monat mit anderen
worten wenn man nicht mit geld bezahlt
bezahlt man mit zeit
dies erklärt warum 25 prozent der
schweden bis zum dreißigsten lebensjahr
bei ihren eltern nehmen
dies erklärt auch warum sich die
schwedische gesellschaft von der miete
ab und zum wohneigentum hin gewendet hat
bei niedrigen hypothekenzinsen kaufen
sich die meisten schweden lieber so
schnell wie möglich ihre eigene
immobilie und was passiert nun mit den
menschen die nicht in schweden geboren
sind was passiert mit einwanderern die
keine familie haben bei der sie erstmal
wohnen können so in diesem fall
willkommen in der wunderbaren welt des
privaten wohnungsmarkt in schweden
grundsätzlich herrscht in schweden die
meinung vor dass man mit vermietung kein
geld verdienen sollte es gibt dort eine
menge gesetze welche eigentümern das
vermieten verleidet oder gar ganz
verbietet langzeitverträge zb sind
verboten aber selbst wenn man einen
mieter mit einem einjahresvertrag haben
will kann einem die hausgemeinschaft die
erlaubnis dazu einfach verweigern
ja das hat ja richtig gehört die
nachbarn können bestimmen ob jemand
seine wohnung vermieten oder licht diese
vielen beschränkungen erklären den
umstand dass es so gut wie keine freien
wohnungen gibt und so müssen trotz des
aufgeblähten schwedischen sozialstaat
viele menschen in 20 quadratmeter
wohnung hausen wenn er jetzt aber glaubt
das problem wäre einfach nur geringerer
wohl grund vorliegt denn ganz falsch in
schweden geht nämlich folgendes ab
denen untersucht unruhen in einem
hauptsächlich von migranten bewohnten
vorort von stockholm
so sieht es aus als jene armen
einwanderer denen kein hit startup eine
villa kunterbunt bezahlt müssen in die
unattraktivsten viertel der städte
ziehen und so entstanden im land von
pipi langstrumpf soziale ghettos mit
jener hohen bandenkriminalität von der
sicher auch schon gehört haben
darüber werden wir aber in einem
zukünftigen video sprechen und wenn du
dieses nicht verpassen möchte es ist
jetzt der richtige zeitpunkt auf den abo
button zu drücken und anschließend auch
aufs glöckchen denn jede woche
veröffentlichen wir brandneue videos mit
denen du deinen horizont erweitern
kannst kommen wir zurück zu unserer
schwedischen geschichte
natürlich könnt ihr die wohnungsnot in
stockholm durch den bau neuer wohnungen
gelöst werden aber selbst wenn der staat
80.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr bauen
würde wie viele vorgeschlagen haben
müsste auch die miet gesetzgebung
dringend renoviert werden um auch den
privaten wohnungsmarkt wiederzubeleben
davon sind die schweden jedoch nach wie
vor weit weit entfernt so und jetzt
fragst du dich vielleicht aufwändig in
diesem video nur wieder mit problemen zu
texten wollen aber nein nein natürlich
wollen wir dich nicht in
hoffnungslosigkeit ertrinken sondern die
auch lösungen präsentiert ja es gibt
auch positive beispiele von städten die
ihre wohnungs problem in den griff
bekommen haben also nichts wie los
[Musik]
wien und wohnen für alle österreich ist
bekanntlich eines der wohlhabendsten
länder europas das durchschnittsgehalt
liegt hier war über 2700 euro im monat
und wenn man in wien lebt ist es nicht
schwer auch einen job zu finden der zum
beispiel mehr als 3500 euro im monat
abwirft und trotzdem befinden sich die
mieten auf dem niveau viel ärmere städte
wie zum beispiel madrid für 1500 euro
bekomme nur eine sehr komfortable 80
quadratmeter große wohnung direkt in der
stadtmitte und ich weiß was du hast
vielleicht denkst ja mag du wirst mir
jetzt wieder eine weitere geschichte
darüber erzählen die eine stadt mit
hilfe des freien markt ihr glück fand
richtig nein das gegenteil ist das
[Musik]
eine dienststelle der wiener
stadtverwaltung namens wiener wollen ist
der größte vermieter der stadt und ihr
gehören so viele wohnungen dass die
stadt wien sogar der größte
immobilienbesitzer europas ist die ist
es dazu gekommen nun nach dem ersten
weltkrieg herrschte unter den wiener
arbeiterfamilien sehr großes talent
deswegen beschloss die frisch gewählte
sozialdemokrat in der stadtverwaltung
für diese verdammten arbeiter kommunale
wo siedlungen zu bauen so entstanden die
ersten 64.000 gemeint wohnungen im
zweiten weltkrieg wurde dann aber halte
wien durch bombenangriffe zerstört nun
beschloss die stadtverwaltung den
wiederaufbau kräftig zu finanzieren und
wie man so schön sagt er zahlt bestimmt
bekanntlich die musik daher wurde der
magistrat auch die bedingungen bestimmen
zudem vermietet wird und so begann das
weltweit ehrgeizigste öffentliche
wohnbauprogramm heute leben 80 prozent
der wienerinnen und wiener in
mietwohnungen und 60 prozent davon sind
sozialwohnungen einige dieser gebäude
sind in genossenschafts business und
andere gehören direkt der stadt
allerdings reden wir hier nicht über
normale mietverträge tatsächlich handelt
es sich fast um eigentum nur mit
einschränkungen im grunde haben
mietverträge in wien ewig lange
laufzeiten über den tod eines mieters
hinaus ja denn die mietverträge können
auch vererbt werden also solange du
nicht um sie ist christ du sagen die
wohnung gehört quasi die und glaubt mir
derart qualitativ hochwertige wohnungen
will keiner mehr ohne guten grund her
gehen und während in vielen ländern
sozialwohnungen er nur für ärmere
menschen gedacht sind und diese sich
dann eher schlechteren wohngegenden
befinden ist dies ihnen wie ganz anders
beste laden top ausstattung mit
schwimmbädern fitnessstudios und sogar
saunen in einigen fällen führt dies
sogar zu recht absurden situation wären
wir für dieses video recherchiert haben
sprachen wir mit dem wiener rathaus über
so einige fälle zum beispiel gibt es
eine junge frau die in einer 80
quadratmeter großen wohnung im zentrum
der stadt lebt was glaubt ihr wie viel
miete zahlen muss 400 euro aber ihren 8
da in einer ähnlichen wohnung lebt zahlt
2000 euro der grund seine wohnung gehört
nicht der stadt wie in stockholm gibt es
also auch in wien zwei arten von
mietwohnungen mit regulierten und
unregulierten bieten und jetzt fragt ihr
euch vielleicht wie kommt es das ist
hier keine langen wartezeiten geht
schweden nun hier kommt die antwort
[Musik]
jährlich gibt wie in etwa 600 millionen
euro für den sozialen wohnungsbau aus
zum vergleich deutschland mit einer
bevölkerung die mehr als 45 mal so groß
ist wie die von wien die bundesweit rund
400 millionen euro aus so und jetzt
verraten wir dir noch wie dieses ganze
wie das system eigentlich funktioniert
nehme an du siehst nach wien in den
ersten jahren kann man noch keinen
antrag auf eine sozialwohnung stellen
aber das stellt auch kein großes problem
dar denn mehr als 290.000 wohnungen sind
auf dem freien markt es ist also nicht
schwer ein geeignetes plätzchen zu
finden denn die preise sind nicht
übertrieben hoch eben aufgrund des
großen angebots nach zwei oder drei
jahren kannst du dich für eine
städtische wohnung bewerben dann kommt
es auf seinem familienstand einkommen
und auch darauf an wie wählerisch du
bist normalerweise beträgt die wartezeit
aber nicht mehr als zwei aber natürlich
ist wie wir bei visual politik immer
sagen auch hier nicht alles nur eitel
sonnenschein das erste problem bei
diesem system besteht darin dass du
nicht mehr aus deiner wohnung ausziehen
willst wenn du sie erst mal gefunden
hast
[Musik]
das modell schwenkt eine wahlfreiheit
recht stark ein
im grunde genommen ist nicht nur die
wohnung aus sondern die stadtverwaltung
für dich das ist vor allem deshalb
wichtig da die wohnung und ihre lage ja
einen sehr starken einfluss auf deine
lebensstil hat aber es gibt hier noch
ein anderes thema die nachhaltigkeit
dieses system stützt sich auf nur einen
akteur den städtischen dienstleister
wiener wohnen so landet der magistrat
also über genügend geld verfügt um seine
sozialwohnung programm zu
subventionieren sind keine größeren
probleme zu erwarten aber es braucht nur
eine krise der städtischen finanzen und
das ganze system dieses reichhaltigen
wohnungsangebot gerät in gefahr und da
ist aufgrund eines mangels an anreizen
nicht viele private bauträger gibt die
für die stadt einspringen könnten kann
eine wohnungsnot dann leicht eintreten
und das würde dann zu einer menge
sozialer probleme führen wie wir in
schweden sehen können wir müssen aber
zugeben dass dieses modell bisher gut zu
funktionieren scheint
die frage ist nun also wäre es möglich
dieses wiener modell mit einer
marktwirtschaftlichen lösung zu
kombinieren glaubt ihr dass dieses
system auch in anderen städten anwendung
finden könnte würde es mich persönlich
etwas ausmachen eine wohnung auf
lebenszeit zu mieten wer die bedingungen
dort gut genug wären wir immer sind wir
gespannt auf eure kommentare
bevor wir aber zum schluss kommen möchte
ich mich noch bei max solo und kardinal
für die hilfe bei den fakten über
stockholm bedanken
außerdem möchte ich dem wiener rathaus
für den mitte und zuvorkommende
beantwortung unserer fragen danken
falls euch dieses video gefallen hat
geht uns bitte einen daumen hoch
abonniert unseren kanal und macht's gut
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]